i call to order the meeting of the house
health human services and elderly
affairs committee for the purpose of
looking at six bills that had been put
into interim study
we um
this is not a public hearing so that
people do not sign pink cards and
testify
it is somewhat like an executive session
except
we do not craft amendments what we do is
we look at the bills before us and we'll
make recommendations either that we
think it's worthy of representative
webber what's the exact term
sorry
sorry either recommended for further
legislation or not recommended for
further legislation and
i am just remembering that i don't think
and
maybe our researcher can help me with
this
i don't think we write minority reports
on this but i'm not sure do we we don't
okay so we could simply write a report
that says the committee was divided as
to whether further net legislation was
needed
and i'm taking it also as here are
salient points that the committee
brought up yeah um
i have suggested to
stakeholders and bill sponsors and
co-sponsors that they either come or
send a representative because this bill
was not passed it's
and it was too good to kill but not good
enough
to uh otp it's in twilight zone and we
will make suggestions that we think will
improve the build to give it a better
chance when it's refiled and you don't
have to take our advice
but then again we don't have to pass
your bill
so it's wise that you find out some of
the things that we say
so we all look like fools together or
you rewrite the bill according to some
suggestions we're making now i am going
to try to jot down some of those things
for the purpose of
the blurb
before we look at our first bill i have
several copies of the executive summary
of the division for behavioral health
for the 10-year mental health plan and
in case i only have
eight but i'll pass them around if you
don't have one feel free to take one
if you don't have one and we've run out
feel free to
get one from dhhs
also
the
issue
of the
long range plan for
the developmentally disabled community
is
by law
to come to this committee it did not go
to oversight
and there are questions by the
developmental services quality council
as to whether the plan thank you
as uh published
um is wise or not
and so in wonderful hhs and ea committee
style
i thought it might be a good idea to
bring together a few representatives
from the department and a few
representatives from the
developmental services quality council
for the purpose of
our trying to square the circle which is
what we're good at
and see if we can find some common
ground
between the two groups to come up with a
plan that's better than what either side
had thought possible
this
will require the formation of an ad hoc
committee
i discussed all of this with the speaker
at a party on
saturday and he said go for it
this ad hoc committee must meet in
public
it must be advertised in the calendar it
is a meeting
not something that we can do informally
at tandy's okay
i would like to appoint to this
committee
myself
uh representative mcmahon
representative weber
representative knurk and um
madame ranking member who was the fifth
one that we talked about yeah of course
of course representative shapiro
and i plan on doing this um in one
morning that's it
we are not crafting legislation we are
trying to look at ways forward
where the concerns that are allowed and
growing can be heard and addressed in
ways that are also doable for the
department
i've asked our committee researcher
to come up with a side by side
so she is finding the plan from dhhs she
is reading the objections from the
quality council and on each sub
item
she will be doing side by side so we can
see what one group is doing what one
group wants and so on
and
we will be announcing a time on that
shortly
yes
as as the chairman of the last 10-year
plan
i would also like to be on that
uh committee i think i'm probably the
most knowledgeable uh
person which is not necessarily a great
asset but
well censor you are in now year two of
your life's next 10-year plan
yeah
sure do we have a republican who would
like to be on that
as you know my day job believes in
conversions
anyone else
yeah thank you i was about to write
representative acton anyway thank you
all right may i remind you that we
debated that once about six years ago
[Laughter]
which
conversions you and me we did didn't we
yeah
we hope it's never mind
no
uh
all right
now house bill 247 is dr nagel here
wanted to make sure okay and that we're
going to be taking another bill out of
order after this one so you can get back
to your patients doctor you are
exhibiting great patients thank you sir
247 relative to treatment alternatives
for opioids and
members of the committee uh
get something to say put your hand up
what do you think
what do you think about the bill
representative kanark
i still have a lot of concerns about
this particular bill because
the idea of non
the non-opioid directive
um is a problem for me were they really
we don't normally legislate the practice
of medicine and there's really no
precedent for leg for sort of
legislating a sequence of treatment that
is offered
in particular
a lot of this was in response to the
opioid
death crisis which is a real issue
but what's important is that that the
over prescribing was such a deal for
such a long time but we have really
gotten a lot of control and the data has
shown that the opioid prescribing has
dropped an immense amount
the deaths continue to increase and of
course many of them are from fentanyl
which is not a diverted generally
there's not because of diversion
so i think there's less reason for this
non-operating directive but there are
some really big concerns and this
harkens back to back when i was in
practice because
as a spine doc i would see people who
have been started on opioids and those
would be paid for for example because i
was a border town
in maine they'd buy all the opioids
you'd want they'd only get you two
sessions of physical therapy if you're
on main medicaid physical therapy is a
far better proven treatment for back
pain than our opioids
and this is actually often just for
acute back pain or sub uh you know sort
of short term but not necessarily even
chronic the issue is
there are concerns on coverage now
medicaid is obviously a state issue but
the insurances also don't cover some of
the things it's hard to get coverage for
cognitive behavioral therapy which is a
great treatment
for chronic pain
but you get all the pills you want and
all the injections you want and you can
kind of break it down into the dr fix me
jobs those are things like chiropractic
injections pills
versus the self-actualization which is
what you really need in the management
of chronic pain and those are things
such as cognitive behavioral therapy
acceptance therapy physical therapy
lifestyle changes
those have a far better track record in
managing chronic pain particularly in my
case back pain which is the most common
chronic pain
then are opioids and many times
injections they have their place but
they have a very small place so there
are
coverage issues but the problem with
that is that's not a job for our
committee we know that that falls in the
purview of commerce
we decide something's a good treatment
but their job is to look at the whole
question of coverage and that's if this
bill comes back it should go to commerce
and i think one should strip out all the
non-opioid directive and all that
stuff of dictating to docs what order
they have to do things and instead
just look at the question of how do we
cover
the appropriate therapy and it could
even be labeled
as a title for the bill support for
effective pain care but even this gets a
little dicey in terms of trying to
legislate the practice of medicine but
in this case it's more legislating that
there'd be coverage for appropriate
interventions that do have good
good evidence um
so
my thought is that we
we that this bill should be itl
if the sponsor wants to bring it back it
should come back with something that
would
have to do with instead coverage issues
in commerce for
effective pain management i know that's
kind of a long-winded thing but this was
my life this is what i spent all my
years treating was chronic pain
although our breakfasts are not tax
deductible my wife and i often speak
business
during breakfast and she tells me that
it is her belief that catholic medical
center has a handout paper that they
give to people that make suggestions and
so on so i wonder if
the bill's sponsors might not
touch base with that as a recommendation
uh representative shapiro yes thank you
mr chairman my concern with the
with the part of the bill that mandates
coverage from
insurances for various activities is
just that
and i don't know how to solve this
problem but it seems random to choose
certain services such as yoga therapy um
how about tai chi um how about
other things that people do that feel is
really helpful to them i don't really
know how to solve that problem
maybe if there's going to be mandated
coverage to do it in a more generalized
way
although i don't think that's a good fit
for insurance companies
i see that as a real problem kind of
picking and choosing specific
um
therapeutic activities which means
you're not picking and choosing others
and i don't really know how to solve
that problem thank you representative
representative weber
thank you and i think i think we're all
arguing in the same direction although
how we get there we may have some
disagreements i i
very much agree
i think we've covered the medical
aspects of it and and i very much agree
with representative shapiro that
um excluding you know favoring one is to
exclude another and that is not helpful
because we all know that different
things work for different people
but i have also worked extensively with
our colleagues on the commerce committee
on medical coverage issues
and i know that for them
the most
likely thing that you can do to get
something through that committee on
medical coverage is to make it as narrow
as possible rather than as broad as
possible
so
i think that
tactically what one might want to do is
first of all start with
the professions that are the most
licensed and regulated
because people will be more comfortable
with that in an insurance capacity
and think about mandating
certain coverage
for say
chiropractic care or osteopathic care
because then when we get past that
we have a lot of disciplines that are
far less regulated far less certified
and
you
the more you get into territory where
anybody can call themselves a
practitioner of whatever the particular
discipline is the less
likely it is that anybody's going to
approve coverage for that because
they're going to be uncomfortable as to
who's getting paid and
what the quality of the care is going to
be
so my suggestion would be to perhaps
start
with a few bills for coverage
but i i do think that people are far
more
tuned in at this point
to the need for alternative therapies
and the effectiveness of alternative
therapies but i want a second what
everybody else has said is the issue is
getting them paid for and
and that's my suggestion as to how you
do it but there may be other ways as
well thank you representative
representative leon
thank you mr chairman um i agree that
the real issue here isn't about the
availability it's about the paid for
access so this should be something that
moves to commerce i do think that we
need to look broader than just the
providers who are part of this because
there are technologies especially the
tens units the transcutaneous electro
electrical nerve stimulation there's
some that are a lot easier for patients
to apply this isn't the old one with
leads that are everywhere one actually
helped me rehab from my broken femur
about 10 years after because i could
finally work through the pain
so i think that it's important not just
to look at specialties but also to look
at some of these devices especially
those that came through the 510k process
so they don't have the same approval
that you would need for one of these one
of these really really expensive device
approvals but they help they do have
data and if this is something that will
be able to address people's pain get
them back on their feet back doing what
they need to do and get them out of this
debilitating and mentally crushing pain
i think it would be critical to make
sure that we have access for devices
like tens tens as well
representative gay
thank you
um y'all make really great points that i
think ought to be incorporated
in the bill i think we should resubmit
the bill with the the updates that we're
thinking of
i can't take credit for anything except
noticing that on roman numeral one on
line nine
and line twenty they seem to be
contradictory uh line nine
we can add
you know
fine tune it but on line 20 it says a
really good thing nothing in this
section shall preclude a health care
practitioner from simultaneously
prescribing an opioid and prescribing or
recommending any of these procedures
whereas line nine is written
well you have to order this first
before you do an opioid so they seem
contradictory that's something i think
the wording could be addressed
we
it may feel awkward to say we're
specifying certain things and not others
that we think are good
many years ago
when i was going through a divorce and
wanted to go through counseling
i discovered
insurance from state to state really
varied
on coverage so in massachusetts it was
something you know you expect
massachusetts to be very generous
new hampshire in those days 500 was a
lot of money and that was how much they
would cover in mass in new hampshire and
way less than mass so that really
surprised me so i mean we do have a
history of deciding
in by rsa
uh coverage
so
we're not treading on ground that's
never been walked on before
thank you representative canark i think
you want to follow up on that point
actually follow up and also make one
other comment i cannot believe i didn't
make a statement earlier when we talked
about what's excluded
though it would be very difficult to get
insurance coverage for this as all you
know i'm the chair of the therapeutic
cannabis medical oversight board and
actually one of the best
proven benefits of therapeutic cannabis
is in pain and in fact about half of our
patients
uh many of them in our age group i mean
the median age group is 55 to 65
are certified for chronic pain that is
our most common thing and it has
absolutely very good uh benefit however
it'll be a little dicey trying to
mandate insurance coverage for that
given the federal status as a schedule
one drug
so that's out the picture but it's sad
because that's also one of those ones
often underused in response to that
question of the conflict you're right
there was a clear conflict on how that
was worded i objected to that when we
had the hearing is that it doesn't make
sense to sequence this
because there are times and i used to
frequently get semi-started on pt and
continue their opioids because i
inherited them on opioids
the other thing is in terms of
approval
um even for tech for devices and so on
and so forth
i did serve a little while after i
retired
doing some technical reviews for some of
the insurance companies just to review
data on interventions to see whether or
not they should or shouldn't cover it
and as much as we sometimes disagree
with our insurance colleagues and
looking out at
heidi kroll out there about coverage
they do try to you know do a decent job
of looking at it but they are too quick
to cover
um procedures interventions pills and
not the other things that are softer
which again are difficult represent
representative weber made a great point
about the fact that those who are highly
regulated that came up in the hearings
you know yoga that's not regulated so
it's going to be a real problem in terms
of doing reimbursement whereas pt ot
those things are highly regulated and
certified and you know what you're
getting with those and of course they're
already
covered and many insurance companies
already cover chiropractic
many insurance companies already cover
acupuncture and osteopathic anyway so
there's a lot that is covered and i
think this is one of the difficulties is
this fine-tuning
that process legislatively uh is always
a little bit difficult just we want to
make sure people have appropriate
coverage thank you thank you
representative representative shapiro
thank you mr chairman i'll make a
disclaimer and say i'm going to talk
about something i know nothing about um
we do that all the time here sir thank
you
well we do that i thought you said you
do that
i am part of we
so in any case um since it's so hard to
discern
which
therapeutic activities or which um
technologies
um our best or should have approval and
shouldn't have approval and
i'm wondering if
if if
through the commerce committee if
something couldn't be done to kind of
encourage
the insurance companies
to do a more thorough search on what is
useful and what isn't useful something
about the process by which people
petition to have something covered and
how the insurance companies respond to
that
maybe legislation could affect that
process maybe i don't even know if there
is a process
rather than the legislature mandating
specific
therapies and technologies specifically
thank you representative uh we will send
a copy of all of this to representative
chairman hunt for his summer reading
pleasure representative woods ah thank
you mr chair um i'd i'd like to take
more just to make a couple comments
uh how did we get here if we don't know
how we got here we don't know how we can
correct it
uh one of the problems is starting in
the 90s we decided we're going to
deliver health care
on a market-based system rather than a
government-based system
that involved big pharma and we all know
what happened with purdue and we've seen
some of the stuff on tv
and so that
aspect
became a public entity
the other part was perhaps because of a
deficiency in medicine
we weren't handling
patients very well
fortunately i didn't have to because i
had in my office dr nagle
if there was an opioid patient i would
say
i know just who you need to see
so i always had an out by the same token
the government got involved and said
you're not taking good care of your
patients
and you need to understand what pain is
and so
you you have to check when you come in
the office what's your pain one to ten
when you leave the office what's your
pain one to ten
and when you get on the phone well
what's your pain one to ten
and we had this one to ten and the
public became
very intimately aware that oh
maybe i should be getting something
and
the conflation
of the pharmacy
the conflation of the government and
even looking at our chart if they were
to review your chart and you weren't
doing adequate one to ten measures in
your
then you were dinged financially
uh they would retract some of your
reimbursement
um so there was a there's this feedback
and some of that is fortunately
uh we've become more aware of the
pharmacy part
okay uh we become more aware um that in
fact we need when we say one to ten that
needs to be put in perspective
uh and the medical community is
fortunately helping to balance that so i
think some of these forces
are
i think
uh in that pendulum swing and we're
caught in the middle of this at the
moment the thing we don't want to do is
do like we did here in the latest and
not we i wasn't here at the time but
i forgot how many years ago say 20 years
ago there was a hue and cry in the
legislature for coverage of bone marrow
transplants for
breast cancer treatment
and uh the medical community says no i
don't think there's anything about that
um
nevertheless the legislature in its
infinite wisdom
said uh yeah let's uh yeah let's let's
go ahead let's do that but within six
months of passing the legislation it was
found that in fact as the medical
community said there is no rational
basis for it and it's not used
we don't want to fall into that trap so
i i just want to offer a couple of 30
000 foot
comments in light of that representative
i made the mistake once this one to 10
scale kicked in
of saying my pain is three at which
point the doctor said oh if it's only
that go home and watch reruns of
seinfeld
and it'll be good for you so after that
i always said 10 and they said why 10 i
says because it's my pain
and if i say 10 i'm much more likely to
be taken seriously realizing the whole
thing was a farce yeah thank you
uh representative merchant
thank you mr chair
i do agree that this is probably more of
an economic issue than a medical one
however when i say that
if this committee does support
a policy saying these are therapies that
should be considered for treatment it
does help i think in swaying people to
understand what they should be looking
for economically to support
in saying that too i did speak out to
the prime sponsor dr lagran
representative lundgren
and he is willing to put together an ad
hoc group for the summer and i've
invited the stakeholders including
heidi kroll reached out to heidi as far
as the insurance company because they're
critical piece to it and talk about this
issue of what can we do collectively
to solve this issue
legislatively and so forth so we are in
a process with dr nagle some other folks
to actually pull together some
stakeholders
to form an ad hoc group
to work on it
so i don't think it's a question at this
point in time what this committee does
but to let you folks know there is a
group of us trying to get together and
talk about it collectively to try to
reach some sort of consensus because
i totally agree with representative
connor dr kanark
um
what we don't want to do is tell the
medical community how the practice
however
we need to be sure that there's a
part behind what we're trying to say is
that from the legislative body we
believe these are things that should be
considered to be covered how they get
covered there's probably many ways to
skin the cat but without having the
insurance companies at the table it's
going to be impossible to get there
okay let's wrap this up i think we have
i i know
the point of order i just
i'm going to call on you but i'm saying
let's wrap this up so that we can move
on to the next thing and these notes
will be passed on to that ad hoc
committee uh representative kenner yes
actually all i want to do is ask if we
could since dr nagel was kind enough to
come
and spend his time listening to all of
us talking about his specialty
i know that this is not a testimony but
could we ask him for his input and his
feelings about what we have just said
and whether he thinks we're on the right
track dr nagle would you come up and
tell us if you think we're on the right
track
mr chairman
if i one of the other things too i
talked to dr nagle beforehand
is on senate bill 290 which is arico
therapy
this is also dealing with pain
and maybe one of the things for us to
consider and look to hear from dr nagle
his thoughts on this
should we merge the two of these
together into one hot group and saying
why don't we talk about this
collectively holistically and i'll break
it apart
so you have any comments thank you
mister
um
because dr nagel will be addressing 290
290 will be taken out of order next so
he can get back to his patients and um
dr nagle turn your mic on and let us
first you examine it
all right wow and you then you get a
prior authorization
i'm sorry i'm gonna have to call my
secretary now
i'll be back in about four weeks um
that's the next discussion we'll have is
on that but anyway that's the commerce
committee too i guess
um do i need to reintroduce myself
okay i'm dr david nagle um i've been
practicing pain management and conquer
and concord for 32 years
um
i've been involved in legislation for
the prescription of opioids since 1998.
um i actually helped write the first set
of rules regarding opioid prescribing
our see our our purpose has always been
to
have a balance between the issues of
pain and addiction and i will take an
issue with the statements that have been
made about opioids
they do have value for people with both
acute pain chronic pain and especially
end of life pain and because of public
policies that have been coming about
this being one of the cdc
we've been seeing a decreased access to
care because of these people with that
said
the other role that i've been playing in
addition all my roles within the state
is i've been sharing the nfl pain
management committee for the last five
years nflp being uh an actual football
league players association oh yeah yeah
so um i was asked to share their pain
management best practices committee and
the nice thing about that is i've got
interview a lot of people that have a
lot of money while they're playing
football and i've been able to find out
what helps them and what doesn't help
them we don't have a great evidence base
for outcomes in terms of single modality
therapies
we generally feel that most treatments
involve multiple modalities used
together we certainly learned that from
the nfl players the difference between
them and the public and them and when
they retire
has to come down to cost
who pays for this how do you pay for
that kind of thing but we've discovered
a lot of things that actually have a lot
of benefit that work really well that
people don't have access we've been
saying forever that um
if all you're going to pay for is pills
and procedures don't be surprised when
people just get pills and procedures
it's it's really got to change and
there's
an incentive for you to do this now i
brought a copy of this for each one of
you to read the next 10 minutes
as i think you're fully aware the cdc
changed the entire dialogue on pain
management opioid management united
states when they released their guides
in 2016 this is the updated draft
within this draft is a statement that
the right authors of this guide
feel that access to alternative
therapies
is extremely important and that they
will do whatever they need to do to make
sure that that happens so i think that
new hampshire has an opportunity to be
one of the first states united states to
actually enact this kind of legislation
whether it's done to this committee
commerce or whatever
it it's really important the problem
that we had with
247 was the whole statement about
opioids and its entire um
persistence on alternatives to opioids
you need to do this need to do that and
we've actually talked with
representative lundgren we wrote an
amended version of it and he really
liked what we wrote
so
i think what i'm saying is that number
one is please don't punish people that
aren't opioids because they are
benefiting from them there are
definitely people that do secondly
increase access to alternative therapies
and we need to find a strategy for doing
this i think this bill is a starting
point but it needs a lot of work um and
gary and i have been our representative
merchants sorry
and i have been talking about this for
years now about trying to make this real
um
and
and so i think in a sense you are on the
right track
in a long-winded way
and if anybody has any questions
comments thoughts
the chair does
dr representative kenner and i will be
going to atlanta the end of the month
for four days and part of what we will
be doing we'll be talking with senior
people from the cdc great hey so um
we're going
do you want me to give you a list of all
the problems with this i'm sure
that's excess baggage yeah for our plane
flight yeah
um representative weber i was just going
to ask if he could perhaps pass that out
so we could be looking over it while
he's
while we're finishing up
are you are you serious
she's always serious one copy oh
i'm terribly sorry i heard you to say i
brought a copy for everyone and i was
joking i'm sorry i i i can't i'm not
that stupid i
but you know what i
no no if you want i can get you access
to this it's a really important document
it's a very important document could you
give the representative and me a cliff
notes two-pager on that
okay and to the committee sure i mean
it's it's past what we're going to be
voting but we are going to atlanta so it
would be very helpful this is a draft at
this point so it's not a final version
understood important so yeah i can do
that okay thank you mr chair
you can you may we we all of us love
policy
but our task today is to say recommended
for further legislation or not
recommended for further legislation not
to discuss what the legislation
is going to be in its minute details
and if we are to get out of here at a
reasonable time
i'm going to suggest that
you know we're exceeding the task in
front of us we are doing that and would
somebody like to make a motion
representative weber would that way i
remember what the motion's supposed to
be
sure i
i would make a motion but i my motion
would be recommended for further
legislation
um
and
if because i made the motion i would be
constrained to write the blurb
what i would say in the blurb was that
the committee
thought it would be wise to focus
on the issues of
[Music]
access and affordability not only to
these modalities but to others
would that would that be an appropriate
statement i was planning on writing
be my guest
and including what uh my clerk has
written so be my guest get the sense of
the meeting and do with it whatever they
wish so the moment in that case the
motion is simply recommended for further
legislation
second representative leon you know my r
d thing
okay the recommendation is the the
motion is recommend
recommend for future legislation on
house bill 247 clerk please call the
roll
we're all set we have a motion on the
floor and that is the only item that
will be addressed
representative leon yes
representative mcmahon yeah
representative acton yes
representative gay
representative cushman is
absent representative folsom is absent
representative kelsey is yes
representative king is absent
representative co-fault yes
representative delemus is absent
representative weber
representative mckay yes
representative snow
representative canark yes
representative salloway
representative cannon yes representative
natarapam
representative shapiro yes
representative woods yes
representative merchant yes and
representative pearson yes 17 nothing
before we move on to sb 290 um
my ever prescient
um
committee researcher
wants me to say that it is not the
10-year mental health plan that we have
this ad hoc committee on just the
developmental
disabilities section of it i may have
confused
you with handing out a 10-year plan in
general that's not what we're going to
deal with i just had extra copies and
thought people might like it we are
going in the ad hoc committee to
look at just the developmental
disabilities part thank you so much for
that
we're going to look at senate bill 290
now this bill permits with certain
limitations the practice of
auriculotherapy i have been rehearsing
that one or the practice of inserting
needles into the external human
ear
and open for comments
representative leon
thank you mr chairman if we think back
to the hearing on this the stakeholders
who brought this forward
intended for the legislation to be very
different than what was actually brought
forward i think that they had some great
discussions and
looking to the intent that they shared
with us i think is a lot more important
to sort of sketch that out before
anybody gets around to working on the
rsas and the idea of putting this
together with house bill 247 as we're
discussing pain management i think is
brilliant and i think that that would be
a wonderful step forward to move this
forward for future legislation without
well looking at it holistically so thank
you for that idea
i want to thank dr michael
i just want to recognize that where the
thought came from was dr nagle so i want
to recognize dr nagle and his brilliance
not mine thanks
well you're in the best committee in the
house so i'm surprised you're surprised
anyone else
representative snow
mike on sir
microphone on
why do i always have
that's right i do and now i have no
excuse because you're not sitting next
to the clerks or that is why
yeah that's true she takes care
representative soloway will please uh
assume that responsibility for the
duration
i must say i i i listened very carefully
to this testimony about this bill and
the only concern i have it came up in
the fiscal note which was
that this bill the way it's written may
lead to an excessive amount of court
activity and they couldn't really judge
what the impact is going to be on the
court system what it's saying is that
anybody that advertises that this method
will solve any problem like deafness
uh alcoholism smoking any of those
things and the person is then liable and
it's also subject to civil action
and i think the court's very concerned
that they could be overwhelmed and
that's a system that's already very
strained so i think that's an issue you
really have to take into consideration
when you
when you do this i recall the attempt to
say
come to us because you'll feel better
without saying come to us because you'll
feel better and that really concerned me
there's a little bit too much of
wink-wink nudge-nudge in there and
that's where legislation's going to come
well they kind of told me if i did this
such and such might happen and what
exactly was said and wasn't said and
what was heard and the speaker should be
responsible sometimes for false hearing
my general attitude on all of this is i
am much in favor of steps in the process
nurse practitioners before we had a jump
from an rn to a do or an md now we have
physicians assistants and nurse
practitioners and so many of the
professions have such
immediate steps and while i'm in favor
of that i don't know any of those
intermediate steps that don't have to be
trained licensed supervised and so on so
i'm all in favor of let's carve out
another step provided that it isn't joe
schmo walking in off the street corner
and sticking a needle in somebody's ear
so my attitude is if the licensing board
of acupuncture wishes to develop
protocols and standards and licensure
and supervision of individuals
practicing auriculotherapy
go for it but absent that we should keep
our hands off that that's just kind of
my conclusion representative shapiro
next door neighbor representative canark
i was just shaking my head to agree with
you thank you i appreciate that i heard
you
okay um i do have one concern about
rolling 290 in with 247
because 290 even though again wink wink
not not does not report to treat any
disease and so on it was being discussed
as issues to
for mental health for behavioral health
for addiction for a lot of things other
than pain
so it was a little bit of a standalone
that was broader than just pain
my worry is
there are so many good things about
potentially
getting coverage with 247
i wouldn't want this portion of the of a
bill if this if this were rolled with it
to undermine the chance of getting the
other portion of the bill obviously they
could just be stripped out but then
that's then this is never
addressed in other words if uh
if some
omnibus bill as we all hate made it to
commerce and they decided to strip out
the language on 290 then nothing happens
to it if they come as two separate bills
they can be each judged on their own
merit and that may be more productive
your ad hoc group though may still do
some work on that for the issue the
chronic pain but since they were
presenting this even though they
purported doesn't treat disease
as
making having benefits far beyond pain i
think it may be hard to try to link it
with it that was a concern i had
representative merchants speak to that
if you would yes thank you i
think the merits of having eventually
possibly two bills going through the
system versus one being locked together
has some real marriage to it however the
stakeholder community that would be
looking at this collectively probably
the same stakeholder community so we're
trying to at that point in time
work on them simultaneously with the
stakeholder community and leave it up to
a stakeholder community where they
wanted to divide it or leave it combined
but i think at this point in time the
logic of having that stakeholder
community ad hoc group look at this at
the same time as looking at pain would
still be there
sounds good i saw hand over here
representative weber
i i just wanted to clarify following on
the remarks of the chair
the boards can't
i don't believe create new licenses in
of themselves we have to authorize that
and then they do the rules they can't do
rule making except as authorized by us
so um
just saying we're going to leave it to
the board is is not fair because
they have to have some kind of
authorization i think i think that the
um
what i'm hearing here is is that
uh we are all for pursuing these
therapies provided that they are
in fact
appropriately regulated and either
certified or licensed or credentialed in
in some manner
but that the complete deregulation
i would want to see the
statement that the complete deregulation
is not something that i would
ever be voting for i will i want to see
a pro a path
towards appropriate training and and
uh utilization of the methodology but
with appropriate training i concur with
that
would we say then that a bill could be
brought forward saying
the legislature authorizes the licensing
board of acupuncture to develop
protocols for auriculotherapy
licensing training and so on and that
would probably well that go to eda
probably but it
might yeah okay does that sound good
representative gay
when we listened to the testimony on
this
um i was trying to find my notes this
morning because the impression i got was
that it was being proposed as a very
helpful treatment as people were trying
to overcome drug addiction there's
nothing in this bill that says what this
is for
uh and if
and it was also trying to
say that the person could do this could
be trained to do this one
one part of the body
uh without having to be certified for
the whole body treatment which meant
that it would be a lot less expensive
uh at least that was my interpretation
that you could train
multiple people
whereas we don't have you know we'd have
a lot more people
to to do the treatment so i would like
to see that put back in the bill rather
than make this sound like a general
treatment
um
and i definitely i thought
we all recognized that there was nothing
in this bill that talked about training
or certification so definitely i would
like purpose
training
and certification to be put in and i
would like this to be developed
into a real
you know an effective bill
representative shapiro thank you mr
chairman i believe that this already um
this regular therapy is already a sub
certification under the acupuncture
board already and
it seemed that
this bill
maybe maybe as representative leon said
um really didn't read the way people
intended it to but
um
what it seemed to do was
expand that certification that's already
present under the board but reduce the
amount of training reduce the amount of
accountability
and
make more vague what it's actually for
so i think that
while the board of acupuncture can't
create new boards
we should be looking to them to see
and since they were opposed to the bill
as it was
we should be looking to them to see how
they might want to expand the services
that were able to be provided but with
the accountability with the um
certification of training and um
you know with clear limitations on what
this was what these services were for
so
if i hear you correctly we are to ask
the acupuncture board
to revisit this in the light of what
we've been discussing and hearing and
come up with protocols
that
could be
i'm trying to avoid a judgment word here
a nice word for more reasonable okay
yeah
you doable that doesn't compromise the
integrity of the importance of training
licensing supervision and all of that
but could expand
what
people can do at that level
um they're sort of nodding
representative uh
uh just a quick response to that the
the testimony that was provided by the
new hampshire acupuncture nation
medicine association
um really made the point that irregular
therapy is already part of standard
acupuncture
i think we're going to see an
interesting turf battle i'm not quite
sure they're going to carve out some
small subgroup well thus they're
training
when this is something they already do
i think this is again i'm not sure how
much we can charge them to come up with
an answer to this um as we saw there was
a conflict because the person who
presented i think it was elizabeth rob
or the other person had been trying to
get a certification course no plc was
not interested in kind of covering the
course as it was defined
so
this is something that i'm not sure
they're going to get together and
suddenly come up with a kumbaya moment
and have an answer on that i'm not sure
i think looks like gary has something to
say about that i'm going to call on
representative weber first of course
the eyes in the back my head will work
once again i think we are at the point
where
that is something that needs to be
addressed by those people who are
interested in pursuing the legislation
with the appropriate people and part of
that is a discussion with the folks at
oaplc
about the
authority that they have the authority
they don't have what they're willing to
do
and then an evaluation of whether we the
legislature want to simply affirm that
or want to change the scheme as it
currently is but that's not a decision
that i think we're going to resolve
today because that's
why we interim studied the bill to begin
with so i would move um
recommended for further legislation if
that is an appropriate motion at this
time mr chair uh i would hold that for a
minute because i have a few people who
would still like to speak and
representative cofoult
thank you mr chairman yeah i'll i'll be
quick i i i just think uh somebody i
know somebody who benefited from
this treatment by a certified
acupuncturist some years ago we heard dr
nagle say a few minutes ago that one of
the most important things that we can do
is to expand access to alternative
treatments
and as such
um i think we're all clear that this
needs to take some um different form
than the form that it came to us in but
i think it's uh important and i i will
be supporting the uh the motion thank
you anyone else representative snow hey
look at that
he did it even an old guy can learn
i'm just wondering
line 14 and 15 on the bill
maybe i'm the only one in the room that
doesn't understand this any person who
violates the vision of this section
shall be guilty of a class a misdemeanor
if a natural person in a felony if an
other
person what is the difference between a
natural i've always wondered that
thinking like
a supernatural person like an angel or
something you know i really wondered
representative weber knows
a natural person is a human being
corporations in this country in in
legal parliaments are also persons which
is
bewildering but a legal
reality but they are not natural persons
because they're corporations thank you
any other that's the cooperation i i
think i think getting into
the specifics of a bill that we don't
think ought to go forward in its current
form is probably not productive but
so one of the questions that the
acupuncture
board is going to look at is to what
degree do you think it is appropriate to
carve out
one aspect and i don't mean to be snarky
but let me give you an example
if ears
are a carve out with specific training
practice limited to ears
could we do one for shoulders
and i'm not making fun of it i'm just
saying if you carve out one thing
why this thing and that would be
something you would wrestle with and
also at the same time wonder if you want
to go carve out some other things too
and so i agree
dr woods the final speaker and then i'll
take the motion uh yeah i understand
you're i understand your concern but
years ago many years ago my
great-great-grandfather was a
self-taught horseback doctor
uh we eventually got uh
surgeons and internists and the surgeons
became this and that and the other thing
and lo and behold
i became a hand surgeon
and we carved that out and i jokingly
said i even just do the left hand
because it's so
the right hand is too complicated
uh i think this is a natural progression
and i think if it's done under the aegis
of
manpower usage which i think is one of
the issues
but just just because
we need more vascular surgeons doesn't
mean you hire a plumber because they
deal with fluid in pipes
so my sense is
under the right circumstances and this
is the question i think and we should
have a look at this
and to see if it can be expanded along
those bases i think it's a natural
progression
so i would say
yes so dare i comment that being a
left-handed surgeon
some could accuse you of being sinister
and no one adrit
oh he remembers his latin sinister for
left
wow
thank you representative weber if you
would make your motion please
i was hoping somebody would have
forgotten that i did that but um
i i move that um
this be recommended for further um
legislation and along the lines of our
discussion
and someone on the side of the
playground other than representative
merchant representative cofolt
seconds it
and the motion before us is recommended
for further legislation on senate bill
290 and the clerk please call the rule
representative leon yes
representative mcmahon
representative acton yes representative
gay
representative cushman is absent
representative folsom is absent
representative kelsey yes representative
king is absent representative cofault
yes representative delemus is absent
representative weber
representative mckay
representative snow
representative kanerk yes
representative salloway representative
cannon yes representative nutter epham
representative shapiro
representative woods
yes representative merchant yes
representative pearson
yes 17-0
17-0 representative webber would you
mind writing the report on this one
i took good notes on the first one i
didn't take good notes on the second one
but i will i will cobble them together
like your chair to do that one too no
i'm i'm perfectly happy to do it mr
chairman and you can amend it in any way
you see that fit when it comes in
definitely do that because i recall all
the changes you made in my blurbs last
term
[Music]
not without permission indeed so
and the chair just offers as an aside
how well the clerk is
doing and we have a
job opening next turn
all right
and not run away
thanks for coming folks
you see and why you feel so at home here
this committee is not above a good
needling of each other
i had your eel
i'm glad we're going to go forward with
us yes van gaal forward okay oh good
ad hoc
they're well they i will anoint them if
they wish but they're ad hoc
let's be a little careful here i mean
you have one ad hoc committee that you
have appointed that is a subcommittee of
this
committee and it's labeled an ad hoc
committee
any
set of members that is less than a
quorum of this committee can get
together and discuss whatever they want
with anybody they want at any time they
want
but if
they are more than a quorum of this
committee unless they are a political
caucus
they may not meet without following
the dictates of 91a so if there's a
smaller group of five or seven people or
nine people who actually want to just
get together and talk to this
you can do that but it's i want to make
it clear it's not an official committee
or subcommittee
there's a couple of ways to do it and
and if i may mr chair
what often happens
is that
the whole committee or a subsection of
it
works on a bill all
summer sometimes that has happened
sometimes people have done as our chair
has chosen to do is say we are going to
make a recommendation
and there is no further obligation once
we have taken the vote
there's no further obligation on this
committee as a committee
but any member who wishes to work on an
issue
has that right so long as they don't run
afoul of the right to know law it's just
it's not an official
anything
and and and
those are the two ways we've done things
i mean if if a committee chooses to work
on the interim study bill as a committee
then you don't vote on it till sometime
in october
but that's not the route that we've
chosen here
the reason i chose to make
the developmental
delay group
an official
subcommittee is because first of all
that council
by law
reports to the committee
so there is an official thing that isn't
in these other groups and secondly
several of us in this room are members
of the joint legislative dhhs oversight
committee where dhhs reports
so because of those official connections
it seemed better to me to make this an
official ad hoc group of or subcommittee
of the committee and let the other ones
go the way
we can with more flexibility
go ahead
uh is it a violation 91a since we won't
have a new bill
officially named is it a violation of
91a if we just all emailed each other as
we thought of things would that be a way
for everybody to participate who wants
to without violating anything
um
it is somewhat sketchy because we
even though we voted on it we still have
a bill in front of us i don't know and i
would direct that question to house
counsel because i'm not going to
whoever's yeah whoever's pulling these
groups together should get clearance as
i did from the speaker's office about
the official subcommittee but but the
the issue of emailing the entire
committee and having a discussion among
the entire committee that is out of the
purview of the public eye
is really
not a good policy in my opinion that's
just my opinion
um
whether whether house counsel says
that's an official violation of 91a or
not i don't know
the other thing to go back to the
different sort of ad hoc committee that
the chair just proposed
is that committee is one that has a very
diverse bunch of people who are
interested in it
and requiring public notice for that
ensures that anybody who has an interest
understands that the meeting is
happening and gets to come and at a
minimum listen if not
participate so
it's two different things that's what
i'm just trying to find out how what's
the correct way to do an ad hoc
committee that does not have
all the legalities that are so you have
generally speaking in half less than
half of the committee less than a quorum
of the committee can get together and do
anything they please without having to
report anything to anybody committee
researcher
just whispered in my ear it would be a
violation to go over half of the members
you shall not email the committee to
discuss this how do we find out who's
interested in working i'm interested in
working because whoever is pulling the
ad hoc committee together will be the
gatekeeper i will more than glad to
invite you thank you we're moving on uh
yeah you just i think one thing is the
whole difference i mean first of all you
didn't appoint this ad hoc committee
this is something that gary came forward
sorry merchant said came forward and
said i've gotten together some people
this is the same thing as we did with
the vaccine bill because we didn't need
an official committee it was just simply
i kept working behind the scenes with
gary and others until it became clear
they were irreconcilable differences and
the bill needed to die
but it's it was you know that's where a
sponsor or other people start to work
together and we all should do that when
we're generating bills anyway is work
with stakeholders and that's what
merchant is going to try to do but it's
not something that we're doing as our
committee he's taking it on because he's
a good dubi
so if you're interested give your name
to representative merchant
and
he will make sure that we do not have
more than half of this committee as part
of that group its limit is 10
10 people maximum
all right that one's done and now house
bill 602 relative to reimbursements for
telemedicine
and uh you've got the
you've got the should have the bill
before you and um
not seeing representative edwards
osborne or hunt representative woods
wrote the committee report when this
sale through 21 to zip would you like to
speak first
um yes i think in this particular
situation with the
uh commission still in place
um
i think
we
this committee recommending legislation
would preclude the activity of that
commission
so and the the answer uh indirect answer
would be yes i think legislation does
need to go forward
but
i think the caveat should be that in
fact
that should be at the discretion of the
commit
recommendations of the commission
so i vote for it but i vote against it
if that's sufficiently clear
i mean they're thinking
as written
you vote against 602 as written
but you want to work on it well i hands
please before speaking the answer the
answer to that is yes i think
telemedicine
uh is like the reference uh to my
great-grandfather being a horseback
doctor and we've changed
i think uh telemedicine was clearly on
its way telemedicine with the covid
situation was
brought for and it was very clear we're
not going back
the question is how exactly are we going
to do that we need to do it properly and
i think the commission
um and i'm no longer on that
representative connerk is uh and i think
we should hear
uh
what they have to say and their
recommendations uh rather than just a um
categorical yes
i mean i wouldn't have any trouble
saying yes we need more legislation uh
but it has to be understood we want the
understanding that we know the
commission is in place
representative shapiro yes thank you mr
chair um
looking back at this legislation two
specific
um changes that this legislation would
cause are
um doing away with audio only
telemedicine
and also um
doing away with
the mandates for parity in payment
and so um
i i'm i'm not sure
i mean i i have a feeling about whether
those should happen or not but i would
agree with representative woods that
that should um
we should have more information and
recommendations from this commission
before we
alter the legislation that's in place
regarding telemedicine representative
weber
while i agree with the two previous
speakers that yes we are going to be
looking at
uh legislation within the vast realm of
telemedicine going forward
i think in this case we should look at
this very specific bill which has very
specific recommendations which i think
are very very harmful
and i would rock i would not vote for a
um
further recommendation further
legislation recommendation on this bill
i think the specific content of this
bill
is
not appropriate i do agree with the
suggestion that this be left to the
commission and if the commission has
recommendations they can
do that and i have no objection to that
appearing in a report but i want to make
it clear that my vote is against further
legislation of this specific sort
since the blurb which i'm not going to
ask you to write on this uh we'll give
some guidance and suggestions would you
care to enumerate some of the harmful
recommendations
in your opinion
i believe that representative shapiro
just gave them
the
elimination entirely of telephonic
communications
is
harmful i'm thinking of
waking up one morning with an attached
tick and calling cheshire medical
center's emergency you know
emergency care whatever it is the
walking care and saying got a tick need
doxycycline and they said fine we'll
call it into your pharmacy that took us
two minutes and i didn't have to drive
to keene
nor did i have to get my telephone and
try and figure out how to focus it on
where the tick wasn't anymore
it it
it is a very effective modality for some
people for some purposes
and barring it seems to me to be very
harmful and
the issue of parity is the other issue
that i think is
would be very
harmful as well so those are my concerns
representative shapiro
yes um
i had a long tenure at the local
community mental health center monadnock
family services and now i'm on the board
and they report that um
audio only telemedicine was really um a
lifesaver for them during covet because
um
many of their clients are poor um unable
to keep um and use technology
in a way that
allowed for audio visual
telemedicine and
to keep in touch with people to do case
management over the telephone was
essential and incredibly helpful to them
and the fact that they could actually
bill for it
was helpful to their bottom line and
helpful to them staying
alive
the ceo of some small facility in
kingston
i would agree with both those points
that's what we faced representative
knurk
yeah i i agree completely with what rep
webber said and i think the difficulty
as rep shapiro just pointed out is
it by taking away audio only it
disenfranchises a significant number of
people who do not have internet access
do not have skills to use it or do not
have the appropriate equipment to be
able to do audio only so that's a
concern
the lack of parity now the issue is that
the 1135 waiver which is what kind of
allowed us to be able to do these things
during covet is still in effect until
the end of 2023 because they need to
gather up some more data to figure out
where things are going there's actually
a build before congress to also look at
the question of making permanent
the parity
and the audio only
and cms is apparently considering even
just doing it for some cpt codes for
example in behavioral health where it's
proven itself to be very
very good and the telehealth commission
is still working so i would agree so
much with brett weber this particular
bill should just not go any further
should not even be considered should be
considered itl
any other recommendations should be
coming from our commission that has been
working hard at this for a very long
time and not us trying to do an end run
around them which is really what this
did it was an end run to take away
some very good things that should stay
until we decide what to do thank you
representative representative leon
thank you mr chairman i i do see this as
these two different issues i believe
that telephone only telemedicine is a
very important offering and it's
something that doesn't fill every need
but it is important but there are also
other telemedicines that don't really
step up to that same level as of a visit
so the idea of parity for all telehealth
i think could be very stifling on access
to some of the opportunities that i had
explored in the medical device space in
order to better keep tabs on what was
happening to patients if you're looking
at remote reading of a cardiac monitor
you're looking at some of these other
things when you're able to have some
access to see what is going on with the
patient it does not re meet the same
standard as a visit but it's very
important to that ongoing maintenance of
patient health and keeping them from
deteriorating and getting to a more
expensive and more importantly
deleterious to their health circumstance
because we want to make sure that these
patients with
with um especially with with these
devices that can transmit with these
other ones being able to check in on
somebody and make sure that they're not
starting to decline is crucial and if we
require parity then we're going to see
more gatekeeping on this and i think
that there are a lot of services that
whether you're in person or you're doing
telemedicine some of them should have
parity absolutely but not every single
situation so i think the idea of
exploring parity has a lot of value we
need to be able to look at
which are less than telehealth instances
and which ones are those full service
telehealth visits that do deserve to be
paid on par
so i think that it's a very important
issue it is one that should be discussed
i think that is it is something that
should see further legislation but
perhaps deferring to the group that's
already been formed on telemedicine
would be appropriate but i don't want to
slam the door on the idea of parity
because i believe that enabling these
you know micro visits is very supportive
of health
representative woods ah thank you mr
chair uh clarification for me
i i guess i need to understand what a
vote
no further legislation
uh does that mean
we're we're debating the merits of the
bill
and i as my understanding was we're not
debating the merits of the bill per se
but my mind was
does this area need further legislation
and and and that i may be operating
under the
the incorrect uh premise we have an
answer representative weber
okay
so here's
this is so different from anything else
we do
and we're all policy wonks all of us
so it's very difficult for us to get
down to this level all we're saying is
recommended for further legislation or
not recommended for further legislation
whichever way we vote on any of these
bills it will have
absolutely no further effect whatsoever
on what happens next year because we
cannot bind the next legislature and we
can say this is
not this bill but
the bill under consideration is the
silliest thing we've ever heard of and
we don't think anybody should waste our
time with it and we can write that in a
report but that the next legislature has
the right to file that bill
and everybody has any right to study
anything they want and bring in a bill
on anything they want
so i think that the important thing here
whether we vote yes or whether we vote
no and i agree that representative leon
has made some very valid points
is that you can write
a report that says
there are some areas for further study
but i think that in this case we already
have a vehicle for that further study
in the commission that's doing the work
and that
we ought to wait for their report and in
in
if you say that you can say that on a
yes vote or you can say that on a no
vote it's
but it's not going to make any
difference in the long run as to what
gets filed
representative merchant
thank you
i believe the critical piece here is
what's being delivered not how it's
delivered
and therefore if we agree or back to the
same thing is that
with representative leon there should be
parity
about what the service is not how the
service was provided
and i think that's probably where it had
the focus of this group or somebody
looking at it and saying is that we have
to have parity
regardless of how it's delivered
but whatever is delivered should be
equal in
reimbursement that's kind of my comments
representative leon
thank you mr chairman and thank you
representative merchant um i think that
makes a lot of sense though one wrinkle
in that is some of these services can
only be provided by telehealth where
where that's where the question of if
you throw out that word parody but i
agree i agree with your sentiment that's
just my little concern in that statement
so thank you
if we said something like at the end of
the report
given everything we've said
about parity
and about uh telephonic
because we agree that reimbursements for
telemedicine is a subject worthy of
further consideration we vote that it's
we recommend for further legislation you
know notwithstanding all the other
things we've said along the way
we think this subject is worthy of
further legislation is that the gist of
representative what you're trying to say
well what i was trying to say on on the
actual bill i mean that's a perfectly
valid way to go um i still think that i
would prefer a no vote on the actual
bill but the points you're making are
all very valid and
sorting them into a yes or a no
is
difficult because
you know it's just amorphous it's not a
yes or no decision my follow-up could be
also rendered
because we agree there are numbers of
items
that we would wish to see differently
we would not recommend
for further legislation i mean we could
say that
uh representative knurk and you could
even say
for further legislation uh under their
purview of the telehealth telemedicine
that's not the motion we can say that's
the preface
no and you're in your blurb in your
blurb because then you're just not just
saying we think more should be done but
we're saying
we identified that we do have this group
that's already been working for a couple
of years
let them do their work and don't try to
do an end run
regarding that parity issue i think
it was sb 390 that we managed just a
month or so ago it was avart's bill and
that's where we did have issues of
synchronous and asynchronous to be able
to cover that but the issue for parity
doesn't have to do with the different
services like i didn't get paid for the
same amount for doing somebody's back
operation as i did for a visit the issue
is parity that if you did a
mental health visit let's take that
because that's much more amenable in
person or in phone you get parity for
payment for that it has nothing to do
with different things so the
asynchronous
study of uh you know reading out let's
say ekgs or whatever
that's going to be reimbursed at a whole
different level anyway and you're right
it cannot be done as an in-person is
done purely telemedicine but parity is
not what we're talking about in that
aspect it's not payment for everything
the same across the board it's payment
for equal services
regardless of how rendered so yes i i do
believe this bill
should not be going forward period
because it's the wrong bill we should
let the tele medicine group
telehealth commission i'm sorry develop
what they think needs to be done and
also let the feds continue to do the
work because that's where they would be
doing some of the work with the cpt
codes
um
too and then we can you know codify what
they come up with
as we need to
because the chair notices representative
snow's microphone light is on the chair
recognizes representative snow thank you
very much you notice i did have my mic
on i did notice a timely way
just to follow up in what representative
shapiro said
having a long history at one of the
community mental health centers i would
just like to bring two things one of the
things the legislature required is that
all the community mental health centers
must have these crisis response teams
available 24 7.
and i had the opportunity to talk with a
family
who the crisis response team responded
to in the middle of the night showed up
worked with the police showed up worked
out a very detailed safety plan
let the person go home so they didn't
have to go to the emergency room the
family was very impressed
that the person that showed up that
night then called first thing the next
morning called the next afternoon
kept assuring them that they would be
seen those were very reassuring to
people
there's been a very safe outcome that
particular person is now fully
functioning again
if that audio thing ever went in
you would not have a team that's large
enough to keep going back that often but
the initial contact was made that way
but the follow-up game in rural areas
if if you if you left that out
especially the rural pool without it it
would really be a disaster and the last
thing is the other thing we often
experience is when we see somebody at
intake or
initial assessment they do show up they
drive a long distance they see you
once the plan starts to come into effect
all of a sudden there are lots of
reasons why nobody wants to drive
that distance again and at least if you
have that
telephone you can check and get pretty
detailed information about how things
are going and what they're doing
and the other thing is that a lot of
people have said that they find it very
discomforting to walk into a place
that's known as a mental health center
where there's other people around who
are mentally ill and they may you know
just because you have it doesn't mean
the stigma doesn't apply to you as well
and it's so much more comfortable being
able to do it at more of a distance even
though there's a pretty personal contact
so i think these are all things we have
to think about as
we go ahead
thank you very much i'd like to draw
this to a close if anybody has something
that hasn't been said
i like to do a straw
poll so we can make the
a positive motion here
if the motion were to given all the
boiler boilerplate that leads up to this
which will be the same either way
how many of you would be in favor of
saying recommended for further
legislation
not recommended for further so let's try
it again now you know recommended for
okay not recommended for oh wow okay
somebody make a not recommended because
that seems to be the majority
who would like to make a not recommended
for further study
i'll make the motion if i can trade you
this one for a regular therapy
you're on
i would move not recommended for further
legislation
it was not seconded so i may have a
point of order
yes
yes and and and i'm going to express the
concerns
about um
uh
audio only calls because that was a
universal and i'm going to say that
we are
agreed that further
clarification needs to be made
with respect to the reimbursement and
charges as to whether
the services are being
are the same services in both cases or
whether the services are
different and therefore subject to a
different pay scale
if if that if that's acceptable that's
the way i would write the bill
the motion has been made but not
seconded do i have a second from this
side of the playground okay thank you
representative gay
seconds the motion of not recommended
for further legislation on
um
house bill 602 would the clerk please
call the roll representative leon yes
representative mcmahon yes
representative acton
representative gay
representative cushman absent
representative folsom absent
representative kelsey yes representative
king absent
representative cofoult yes
representatives absent representative
weber yes
representative mckay yes
representative snow
representative connerk yes
representative soloway
representative cannon yes representative
nutter epham
representative shapiro yes
representative woods
yes
representative merchant yes
representative pearson yes 17-0
uh to clarify a previous aside um you're
not the only one who is trained to be
the clerk you know so should you come
back it would not necessarily have to be
your job
wow you're really trying
i'll take back peddling for 100 alex
okay thank you 602
and may i apologize to the committee for
not having turned my phone off i'm very
sorry oh i thought that was my phone
okay you get you get uh one um we all
get to know one each
uh
12 24
yes
uh 12 24 prohibiting state and local
governments from adopting certain
mandates
in response to covert 19 and prohibiting
employees of places of public
accommodation from discriminating on the
basis of vaccination status and there's
also an amendment in the packet of stuff
who wants to kick this one off
representative leon
thank you mr chairman um
this past year had a lot of different
bills that dealt with covid and dealt
with what the appropriate response to
covid would be what the correct level of
decision making was
and quite frankly almost all of all of
these areas were covered by other bills
that were going through
the legislative process when we look at
section one which is about the mask
mandates both bodies move forward to
prohibit local school districts from
making their own mass decisions
something that quite frankly i think is
better suited to the department of
public health than 204 different groups
who are trying to determine what they've
been told by the department of public
health and try and make a convincing
argument to the school board i think
it's quite disappointing that that bill
ended and that bill was vetoed i think
that
i think that it's i think it's quite
quite scary to put public health
decisions in the hands of an appointed
health team in 200 different locations
among the state so i think that it is
important to try and figure out where
that type of decision should be made in
the future so i think that that first
section absolutely should still be a
focus of legislation going forward
then as we move into section two
some of this was already in law about
government agencies not being able to
discriminate
but
we worked very very hard on house bill
1210 it was trying to determine
what kind of decision your employer
could make about your personal health
decisions
it's been complicated by the whole
regulatory path for the coveted vaccine
i had been part of a vaccine conference
back after sars when we were trying to
figure out how industry and how academia
and how government and how investors
could all respond in order to quickly
bring out a vaccine to deal with a
public health threat
one of the things that was very very
important to all the stakeholders that
were there at that conference was that
the scientific backing of any of those
vaccines would be strong so that people
wouldn't have a question
unfortunately in the rush to get a
vaccine out which i am very very
thankful came out quickly
there was an immediate opportunity for
crossover from the treatment arm
so everybody who had volunteered was
excited about this possibility
and the number of people who crossed
over early on meant that we don't have
long-term data on those clinical trial
participants
sorry uh i apologize i'm getting way too
way too deep in my um into my background
so crossover means that you were
randomly assigned to either get the
vaccine or get a placebo whatever the
treatment is or the control group
crossover is when you reach a certain
point and you say
if i didn't get the treatment i want it
now
this is so important to me that i want
this access i volunteered for it and i
deserve this
and that's something that's allowed in
these studies because otherwise why
would you allow people
why would you have people who want to
get the treatment
volunteer to get it early when there
might be large unknown risks
and then deny them the opportunity to
get that once it's available to the
general public
that's one of those confounding problems
that we have in scientific research and
it's one that i don't think will ever
overcome
because you can't deny that medical
treatment that's available to others to
somebody because they were willing to
put themselves forward and benefit
science and benefit all of us
unfortunately that did away with a lot
of the long-term data that we would
otherwise have and so we're left with
low quality of evidence we have a lot of
information for a lot of people it's the
right decision
but we don't have long-term follow-up
data
as we look at this and we move forward
we have another wrinkle here too
now the fda
the vaccine arm is looking at using a
future framework and they're looking at
well actually so if i can just step back
for a moment i had mentioned the 510k
for some of these devices that's pretty
much an easy approval it means we've
already shown this thing works we've
already shown that it's safe and so you
can make small iterations you can make
small changes and we already know that
it's okay so we'll let you continue
innovating without having to do a big
clinical trial
um what the
order yes we're getting way away from
what this bill says
okay
so if we're looking at whether or not an
employer can force somebody to be
vaccinated with a drug that had
that had challenges to the clinical
trial we need to look to the fact that
the fda is also looking to approve
future vaccines based upon the same mrna
framework without additional robust
clinical trials
because of that we need to continue this
discussion about
where you forfeit your rights to your
employer
and i believe that it's very very
important for us to continue with
legislation on this looking around the
room i'm not sure if we will have a
majority agreeing with me
however i believe that this is very
crucial
and we need to continue this discussion
i've spoken with the attorney general
about the human rights issues of this as
well and there are various avenues i
know that we came in with a sledgehammer
before i think we can thread the needle
to avoid the needle for those who need
to
thank you
are you speaking
in this case representative to the bill
as presented or to the bill as amended
because the bill is amended which i was
prime sponsor and you co-sponsored
limited the entire bill to just
government with no restrictions on
private entities i'm thank you for the
question i am looking back to the
original one i'm just looking at the
entire framework
at the time that we amended it we would
look to the fact that a lot of these
different areas were addressed in
separate legislation that did not make
it fully over the finish line
in about one sentence
why would we need to say yes going
forward what's the gist is it a
study
of the whole subject that you don't
think the individual bills adequately
did or what
thank you i believe that the bills that
we had counted on um did not make it
over the finish line so we need to
address the challenges that came up
among both masks and vaccination
requirements
bring in stakeholders and discuss with
the department to discuss with the
attorney general to discuss with
everybody that we should in order to
find the right right path forward i
wouldn't expect this to be an official
subcommittee but i would i do believe
that this is something that will come
forward and i think it's something that
we should weigh in on let me follow up
my guess would be that a number of
people are already
thinking about if they haven't already
started meeting together in one of these
ad hoc
kinds of doesn't need approval ways
because they're going to be crafting
legislation on the subject of what do we
do going forward with masks and
vaccinations so you're suggesting is
going to be an informal study group
which i would agree there probably is
one and that's
what we're really saying
thank you i guess my clarification is if
we vote no recommendation does it poison
the well when we come back in front of
this committee next year if this
committee says no and somebody presents
it is that a tally mark against it
no no it isn't representative leon and
then
i don't mean
that's representative leon moving along
to now representative weber
at this point we could probably change
seats and take the other role if we were
required to but that does sometimes
predictably i am going to say that
looking just at the provisions of the
bill in front of us which was never
amended because the amendments were
other places
i am a fan of
first of all i
i want to do no harm and i know that
everybody wants to do no harm and
i know that we have different
ways of thinking the best way to do no
harm is so i acknowledge that up front
but
knowing that things in my small town of
walpole are very different from things
in the center of manchester
and also different from things in the
north country where the population is
far more diffused
um
i am a fan of local control in many many
many things
uh so i don't want to prohibit local
people from dealing with local problems
and that's a pretty broad
tenet of my
how i approach legislation
so i don't want to prohibit
people from using a tool that may be
useful
in a phase of this or another
pandemic that we don't know about
um and with respect to businesses as far
as i am concerned if it is a private
business they get to set their rules as
long as they are not violating
the constitution
and people get to vote with their feet
as to whether they and their dollars as
to whether they patronize that business
or not
so um i'm i'm also opposed to the
prohibition on
businesses requiring documentation and
um
the
discrimination on the basis of covet 19
status by state agencies employers or
public accommodation i think we actually
addressed in a couple of ways
so i think that one is moot
i certainly don't think that anybody
should be
discriminated against on the one that we
dealt with was benefits you know
benefits benefit and shouldn't be
conditioned but i think we've dealt with
that one so
my recommendation would be a
not recommended for future
legislation but i understand that that's
um going to continue to be a debate
thank you representative merchant
i would say it's more philosophical
where this bill's was headed
i believe strongly in
state rights versus federal rights
unless there's a constitutional issue at
stake
estates have the rights to do what they
should do based upon their constituents
their voters in their state unless again
back to there's a constitutional issue
at stake
in saying that i think it's the same way
involving representative weber
be very careful how we use the stake
control to tell local municipalities
what they should and shouldn't do
no different than a state being told
what the fed by the federal government
what they can and cannot do
it's a hammer we should use and use very
very infrequently
and that's again it's philosophical is
we should be very careful here in
concord uh trying to make
one-size-fits-all across all of our
cities and towns in the state just like
the federal government should be very
careful what they do
with the states
and it comes to private enterprise
it really is private enterprise
just like we have our own personal
rights and so forth
corporations are people
they should be entitled to their own
rights that they wish
and how we basically constrain
an individual to be natural or otherwise
should be very carefully guarded and
very
infrequently used unless there's some
real overarching reason to do it so
based upon the fact i
look at this more philosophically
we don't want the federal government
tell us what to do at the state level
and we shouldn't have concord tell in
the cities and towns what they should do
at the town level
and definitely staying out of the
realm of private enterprise they as an
individual have their rights as well
thank you mr chairman so
i think my biggest concern about this
bill
was the fact that it is very specific to
covet 19.
um it does not really
even attempt to create protections for
other situations other diseases
in the future
there is a reason why
vaccine trials and and in
medications take it it takes a long time
to approve years
um i i think there is a general sense
that in the case of covid19 and the
vaccines in particular
there was um
to say that there was a sort of a rush
to
to sort of make sure everybody took this
is probably an understatement
you know i think the the prohibition
against
mass mandates at the
local level is something that
was
deemed worthy enough to to pass both
houses of the legislature
has been vetoed
we have yet to see whether that will be
overridden nevertheless
i think the the fact that that passed uh
speaks to the fact that there are some
parts of this bill that are
are worth considering
to the question of passports and
businesses i would say that you know the
question was does it violate
constitutional rights we do have a
constitutional right to privacy
adopted in 2018
that does focus on
government intrusion specifically um
but you know we we have a long history
of uh protecting places of public
accommodation in this country and i
think it's worth
considering that as we
as we discussed this matter going
forward i guess the bottom line is that
the the coveted pandemic
has really raised a lot of questions
that we haven't had to face before or at
least not in my memory
i believe that it is well worth
exploring those topics
and coming to some resolution on
where the boundaries are
and and for that reason
i i think
while this legislation was not the right
legislation
i think that
we we very much need to continue that
conversation
and um and and find that
sweet spot that is that is agreeable
that balances individual rights with the
community thank you thank you um
i studied a little bit about the last
pandemic because you know my degrees are
in history as well and
discovered that philadelphia took a
radically different mandate
to new york with radically different
results and it's been a hundred years
since the whole issue of how do we deal
with the pandemic of this nature and
however we
vote on this bill we've got to study
that whole issue going forward
how do we respond what is that sweet
spot
representatives soloway
thank you mr chairman
uh
just three points
um point number one
uh within the 400 member house
i would say one and a half percent of
the membership has some expertise
in the data and the epidemiology of
disease
however the remaining
98.5 percent take issue and have
considered opinions
which they are very willing to share
data notwithstanding
second point
in health and human services oversight
committee the commissioner of health and
human services lauri shibanet has
appeared before that oversight committee
and has said
quite directly our data on which we are
basing policy is simply
inaccurate we just don't know
what's accurate and what's not accurate
we are making decisions based on no data
given this
we have legislation before us directed
at covid
however
as my esteemed colleague representative
cofolt has pointed out
we have coming down the pike
numbers of new diseases and
i i would point out that not only do we
have covid uh
3ba 2.1.2
among us at the moment
however
covid 4 and 5 have already been
identified and are headed our way
those of you who are younger than age 50
probably ought to think about monkey pox
if you are going to go to a gathering in
a crowded area and rub shoulders with
the hoi polloi and you were not
vaccinated against smallpox
you may be at risk there were only 780
cases as of this morning internationally
but it's probably headed our way
h1n5 the newest version of um
avian influenza is as you know rampant
among your chickens you may find that
your chicken tacos have gone up in price
because we've had to call the herds and
we're beginning to see the first few
human cases that may be coming our way
nipa virus is on the way
we have
my friends
no
good expertise in the house
we have no good data in our department
of health and human services we have
threats coming our way are we going to
rewrite legislation for every threat i
would submit my dear colleagues that
this is probably not a game in which we
should be playing i
would like to support representative
weber's position and say we shouldn't be
here
representative woods
thank you mr chair i just would like to
add a further comment that was made
relative to federal to state
and associated responsibility and then
state to local
i think there is a difference it's not
just a categorical
local control period
local control for
residential virtual commercial zoning
educational parameters
are all fine locally
unfortunately if you have covid
you don't stay
in one town
you travel across the state you affect
the entire state
uh so in that sense i think the
parameters of which we have to view this
in those circumstances are far different
this is a public health issue and
affects the entire state and to leave it
to local control
it's like turning loose um
typhoid mary
that's local control
uh if you let typhoid mary she we know
directly killed 58 people
so i think we have to be a little bit
careful
of extending that analogy
to the public health domain
carefully
representative shapiro
um while i respect um the previous
speaker greatly i just want to um
i just want to give an example of how
local control worked with this in in my
town of keene
keene which was hit very hard with covet
at one point and the hospital was filled
and
things were very difficult
the ceo of the hospital came forward and
was very outspoken in terms of the need
to do something about
reducing the risk reducing the spread of
covid
and um
he was outspoken and the city council to
on on his um request the city council
took up the possibility of a mask
mandate
and there were multiple meetings um
with people speaking in favor of a mask
mandate people speaking many many people
came and spoke against a city-wide mask
mandate
for the most part
while people didn't agree with each
other for the most part it was civil
there was a real dialogue there was some
disagreement about the city council
within the city council the city council
eventually
um did create a mask mandate
in terms of businesses in town and
institutions in town um the same process
the mandate was then um done away with
when the spread had been reduced
then when the spread increased again it
was brought up again
the mask mandate was put in place again
but then it was also ended
against the wishes of some of the public
health speakers
and i think that it was uh for me it was
an incredible um
example
not not so much of local control but of
um
kind of civilian
civil civilian engagement in people
taking responsibility for their own
community
and some people clearly didn't like the
the answer when mass mandate was put in
place
some people were very disappointed when
the mask mandate ended
but i think there's great value in
engaging the community in
conversation about their own public
health that would be done away with with
this bill i also want to just comment
about the fact that
this bill and many other bills that have
come before us
have
used the framework of discrimination
um
i think we've gone
i i know this i know people disagree
with me and i know people's positions
are pretty hardened
but um
for me it's a sad thing that we're
always talking about personal liberty
and discrimination in regard to these
things and we're not balancing it with
talk about public health and the
well-being of communities
um that doesn't really speak to the
specific things that the bill does but
for me
for me that's a big problem and um
i would prefer to vote against um
recommending further legislation
and it went from over here did you but
yeah representative gay had her home
done
betty will do fine
um i think the uh elephant in the room
is that we're talking about mandates
here
um and so we all have very strong
feelings about what you should tell
people and how do you balance personal
liberty with safety for everybody
the part that i suffered the most from
anguish not physically
is that
we support so much information was
suppressed
we're finding out all kind of things now
like
the num
numbers were conflated people were dying
people uh in hospitals were counted as
having
being there because of covid even when
we found out some of them tested
positive but that's not why they were in
hospital
medication
first was prohibited
then certain medication was mandated
there was just so much lack of solid
good information
and that's what
that's my biggest concern i don't know
how to make
change a law to make everybody happy
but
my personal feeling is let everybody
take care of themselves the way they
think is the safest for them
that doesn't make everybody happy when i
want to go around without a mask and
other people are afraid i'm
spreading viruses
but
i don't know any other way to encourage
information to be current
updated educational for everybody as
accessible as possible
it's just that in this past two years
there's been so much that was
financially motivated
promoted by people who benefited
financially
and then we had to just dig and dig and
find research so
i'm still going for
personal responsibility
personal care you know when i had
coveted
i waited two weeks before i was exposed
to anybody even though cdc is saying
oh five days because we think that was a
political decision people were getting
mad about two weeks but you know i i
just would rather
not
be enforcing mandates i would rather
enforce education
free and open
current as the numbers change
thank you representative representative
we're drawing near to the end because
again we're not voting the bill
and there will be no question about it
ad hoc group or groups looking at
various aspects of this this is just to
get out there and into our report some
feelings so a couple left representative
leon
um thank you mr chairman i think this
has been a good discussion and i do
think that the information that
representative snow shared about the
decision making without much data
was actually one of the biggest problems
with this whole experience
everybody was left grasping for what to
do
and
without strong data people came out very
very heavy-handed and i'm actually
fearful for what that's going to do in
the next time when we need to rely on
public health i think that allowing
non-governmental organizations and
others to influence the way that people
operate and then not allow the state to
have a role to say hold on let's stop
and take a look at what data do or don't
exist
allowed people to overplay
the amount of scientific evidence that
we had about our specific risk
mitigation efforts i think that a lot of
this is around
how much information do you have in
order to force these these choices and i
think that
i think the hand was quite honestly
overplayed and that's why there's been
so much pushback i i i hope we don't
have a situation where the data is so
clear because of how great the harm is
in another future situation but i have
confidence that all the people who are
saying
i need to have the chance to make my own
decision would look at those data and
say oh yes i'm staying home yes this is
what i'm going to do and just like when
i was wearing my respirator around which
i guess was
selfish that was still the best way to
protect myself and i want everybody to
have the best tools to protect
themselves so i think i know the way
that we're going on this but i do
appreciate that we need to look at the
right level of response based on the
data so that we don't harm further
future public health efforts
and representative canark
yeah i'd like to take off right on what
you just said in terms of these
the issue of the data um
you know
as some of us in here have done we've
spent our whole life we're looking at
data and we have to understand that
there was when you have a novel disease
that's new you're going to have a lot of
uncertainty
and
i
there's been some sort of accusations
here that about the data it's people
have to understand that sometimes the
reason that recommendations changed is
that the information changed and the the
public health authorities were
quite straightforward some you know in
terms of clarifying why
they changed it because the information
changed
but people were interpreting that as
they didn't know what they were doing
it's the it's the reality of the fact
that we often have uncertainty in the
early phases of anything like this
now the difficulty the comments have
been made about future and that is
exactly the point that i want to make
we should not be addressing this
legislatively
because you can't tie the hands of
public health
public health has to remain nimble we
just talked a little while ago about we
don't legislate the practice of medicine
we also should not be legislating the
practice of public health and the reason
for that is very simple they've got to
be able to be nimble make changes
rapidly as things change on the ground
the legislative process is slow long and
cumbersome this is my great objection to
hb1131
the prohibition of mass mandates was not
just the local control
but it was generic for anything
it wasn't about code it was anything
so if we did have something come through
that was a very highly transmissible but
clear data that we could clearly stop it
with a mask
you would not be able to
put in a mask mandate if you chose to do
so
and the other difficulty is when you
keep saying it's all individual
responsibility we do have a
responsibility to one another
and for example when we say you can't
drive drunk it's your own choice whether
you want to drive drunk but we actually
tell you you can't do that because
you're going to kill other people
i agree it'd be wonderful if it had
perfect data from the beginning the only
time one has perfect crystal clear
feelings about something for beginning
is when you're really dealing more with
ideology and religion because then it's
a belief
in the real world of science there's a
lot of murkiness and our public health
people did the best job they could
trying to make decisions
the bottom line is
we should not be trying to legislate
what they can and cannot do
just like we don't legislate medicine we
don't legislate the practice of public
health because they've got to be nimble
we should not be legislating these
issues
i'm going to speak thank you i'm going
to speak last before we put this to a
vote
i think one of the things that i
observed
was not just
they were very different
opinions
but some
in both sides
lacked
a hint of humility
and because we don't know and data does
change
i've heard the the word science
weaponized
and that's why i asked and i'll use your
academic title dr woods to make that
presentation to us
about the
alleged fixity of science because i
heard people who ought to know better
from all across the spectrum use the
latest scientific thing
as the fixed and final answer which did
invite
some blowback which wanted to kill all
science
and i'm sitting there saying
folks this is
it's the wrong way to do a debate
whatever your ultimate conclusion is
but we still have to respond
and as chairman of
dhhs oversight
i've had several discussions with the
commissioner
how can we have a rapid response of us
because getting a bill through and
having it voted on two houses and
signed by the governor a lot of arguably
good legislation once it's signed has
long since become irrelevant
so where is the rapid response team that
gives input other than
and um
one of my housekeeping items eventually
led to
a wonderful i think
ethics
advisory committee that the thank you
that the commissioner cheered on
it doesn't tell them what to do it does
tell them what certain people think and
we can get that group together
lickety-split
so i'm hopeful as we go forward we don't
trash science but we understand what
science is and isn't
and we keep humility that what we said
in our medical center is these are the
rules we're putting in place as best we
understand it now please work with us
and we didn't shame people who didn't
like what we did and we didn't
give you know merit badges to those
people who are hyper compliant we just
said we're all struggling along in this
thing that affects us all folks and we
want your input but
a decision needs to be made
that would be my encouragement
to
whatever emerges out of whatever ad hoc
groups happen
i'd like to do another straw before we
get in motion so we get a motion that
will pass
the motions possibly are we recommend
for legislation
not this bill but we recommend this
topic for legislation or we do not
recommend legislation on this topic okay
so who would say we do recommend
okay i'm seeing about four and who would
say we do not
okay so i'm going to ask then so that
the motion can be a positive motion
because if it fails we just got to do it
around anyway uh who would make the
motion uh that we do not recommend
prefer the legislation
and we'll get a medical doctor in there
dr
representative canark
uh and who would uh second that if we
can have someone from the republican
side would be very helpful i didn't see
all the republican hands
go up and um would how about
representative mcmahon how are you
disposed to vote on this
so would you second this
okay thank you
that way it's bipartisan
all right the recommendation the motion
before us as the um house bill 1244 we
do not recommend further legislation
would the clerk please call
the roll
i feel like murphy brown
okay representative leon no
representative mcmahon yeah
representing votes no
representative gay
cushman's absent
folsom absent
kelsey absent
bill king absent
representative cole fault
no
delay ms absent
representative weber
representative mckay yes
representative snow yes
representative knurk yes
representative soloway
yeah representative cannon yes
representative nutter up yes
representative shapiro yes
representative woods yes
and representative merchant yes
and uh last but not least um
representative pearson
yes
12 to four
the
recommendation is we do not recommend
further legislation on this
which again as we know is a moot point
because the ad hoc groups are going to
get and study this this summer and the
bills are going to be filed this fall
all right 12
um just to okay so that was moved by
okay
mcmahon second to do
and yes representative can i i'd just
like to make a
comment
if i could uh just sir
i think in the consideration of how
data is handled and the public
perspective with information
or disinformation
one of the things you have to ask in the
scientific vein
is what would happen
if in fact
we had some trials
of a vaccine
or a trial of any treatment for that
matter that looked quite good
and it was a serious
public threat
and yet it quote didn't meet the
standard and we waited and we waited and
we waited
until
the final standard was finally passed
we would be asking the public would now
be asking
wait
we had the preliminary data
and we didn't go forward
and look what we got
and those are the decisions we have to
make
and i think we have to ask ourselves
that question
in each of the pandemics that we're
going to face
know when i chose to get the vaccines
i'd seen data
and i had to i made my decision on the
basis of
risk
what's the odds
what's the odds of me not
what would happen what's the odds of me
getting the vaccine what negative might
happen and i had for myself had a way
because it wasn't clear
i mean a lot of
vaccines now whether you like vaccines
or not we know the number is
infinitesimally small we did not know
that
in my opinion here
so yeah what are the risks what are the
risk of not doing anything what are the
risks of doing something because we got
to do every anything and what are the
risks of doing it too quickly yeah
that's the discussion yes representative
weber
hi mr chairman time is creeping on and
we still have two bills to do and one
will take one minute but thank you for
that um uh who would like to write the
uh report on this
all right and
thank you and going backwards on 642 in
telemedicine nobody got assigned writing
the blurb on that who would
do that and you in your turn said you
would write the blurb on articular
therapy yeah that was the deal we had
wasn't it okay
well indeed thank you
house bill 1271 limiting the authority
of dhhs to mandate vactin vaccinations
and relative to quarantine
costs
it was
uh referred to interim study by a vote
of
21 to zip
uh who would like to speak on 1271
representative leon
thank you mr chairman i i think when you
get down to the core of this bill it was
looking
not at the idea of availability but how
much data and how much
how much agreement was necessary in
order to require an intervention
so i think that
in that little interim space
representative woods had a very good
point about we don't want to hold up
people's access to new therapies and we
don't want to hold up access to things
that would limit the spread of disease
and i'm actually quite thankful that it
was approved when it was what we're
looking at here with this bill in 1271
is when it would be required i believe
that our department of public health has
done an excellent job looking at the
level of data we have
and not overstepping the data that
exists i spent my career on the cutting
edge of data because i was working with
companies before they even were in their
final trials trying to figure out if
something looked like it would be
promising to public health or individual
health and so i'm very comfortable
working in that area of projecting what
we may expect based upon the data that
are available and knowing that knowing
the work that the department has done
i'm very pleased with the fact that
they're still
waiting to see what other data become
available while encouraging those who do
want to receive the vaccine to please go
ahead and get it i think that that's
walking a beautiful balance and i'm very
thankful that the department is not
looking to make this a required vaccine
at this point because of the level of
evidence
because of that you know i think that we
will have more discussions going forward
but i'm not sure how much this specific
bill itself needs to be the one that
becomes a genesis
there is that question about
quarantining this this was actually
looked at the wrong section this was
looking at quarantining of goods um
something that happened off the coast of
long beach for
non-non-contagious reasons for far too
long
and and we know the economic cost to
holding up goods and we've also seen the
economic cost to holding people up in
their homes but that's something that
the state isn't going to be able to look
at what the actual cost of forcing
somebody to stay home is that's why we
need to be careful about when we force
people to stay home without
putting us all at risk and and i believe
that that the department's done a good
job i believe that
requiring a vaccine has a much higher
standard of evidence than making it
available and while i believe that those
kernels are important i do believe that
this one itself doesn't need to be the
seed of things moving forward and i
think i think that the idea of not
recommended for further legislation
would make sense here
representative weber
and i would just state that i i have
come to the same conclusion somewhat
from a different direction but
if representative leon would care to
make that motion i would be glad to
second it
and
for for all of all of the reasons we've
already expressed
so moved
and seconded
any further discussion representative
kanark uh yes i agree and i think this
bill as it came in was a little strange
again the one
bad a bad
citation in statute but also the idea of
adding a two-thirds vote of the
legislature to be able to do it then we
had an amendment that took away
everything and only kept it with
repealing 21p 42a which made no sense i
mean so it's been a bit of a mishmash so
i agree this particular bill
should be put out of its misery
and i think that
the whole issue about how we manage
questions of mandatory vaccinations is
something which we have dealt with we
actually have the sb 288 commission
that's going to already be looking and
although that's again only about covid
but we also have had other places other
bills we've dealt with that had to do
with vaccinations in general so i think
we've also beaten that topic to death
then we can let this bill go so i
support representative leon's motion
all right i'm going to call the question
the motion is not recommended for
further legislation house bill 1270 one
moved by
leon and seconded by weber would the
clerk call the role please
representative leon yes
representative mcmahon
representative acton
representative gay
representative cushman is absent
representative folsom is absent
representative kelsey yes
representative king is absent
representative cofoult yes
representative delemus is absent
representative weber
representative mckay
representative snow
yeah representative canark yes
representative salloway
representative cannon yes representative
nutter upham yeah
representative shapiro
yes representative woods yes
representative merchant
yes
and representative pearson yes 17-0
17-0 uh who is going to write the report
thank you
writes reports
well i have to write them up and submit
them and they go into the calendar they
will be published in the house calendar
sometime late october early november
and no further action is taken they're
just published
and now last
house bill 1290 establishing a task
force on precision medicine and
biomarker testing you will remember
the late and much missed representative
rogers came before us
and the reason we didn't want to go
forward with it is that we felt a
subcommittee of
the joint legislative dhhs oversight
committee would be the better venue for
this to take place and the reason we
sent it to independent study is to say
itl is a negative and we didn't wish to
say that it was a great bill it was just
not the vehicle we all thought was was
the best way to do it so we sent it here
so that we could have another
opportunity
to celebrate not only this bill but the
life and career of representative rogers
um
and
i don't know if there's anything else to
say
but we can say it anyway representative
weber
i would simply move not recommended for
further legislation on the basis that
the issue has is being addressed under
the guidance i believe of our own
representatives alloway
and that the committee thanks
representative rogers for
raising the issue and bringing it to our
attention but that no further
legislation is needed because it is
being addressed elsewhere
representative leon
thank you mr chairman this is actually
another one of the areas i was involved
in in my previous career well over a
decade a decade ago i worked with a
company working on biomarkers to detect
for cancer
we just got this in the mail they're
presenting at the american society of
clinical oncology and they're still not
yet approved i'm very thankful that the
oversight committee is working on how we
can bring this forward but it's not even
really ready for approval by the fda so
it's definitely not ready for
specific encouragement within the
legislature so i'm thankful that we
moved this forward and we honored our
dear colleague
representative soloway say some things
about the the group that you're you're
pulling together please
[Music]
i was
pleased and honored to be working with
representative edwards who disciplined
the chair in the course of conversation
with representative pearson
representative woods representative
marsh
it was a very worthwhile conversation
again
the chairman that was me was
severely disciplined by the committee
and the final report went from being
eight single spaced pages to two
the world has changed
um
if you let me put this in perspective
because i just have a couple of minutes
you may know that you can now get into
a car in san francisco and it
automatically drives you to your
destination without a driver
hyundai just uh
had a ship
dock on the west coast
having crossed the pacific um
guided by artificial intelligence
the world has indeed changed
representative rogers of blessed memory
not didn't just see
the emergence of precision medicine she
lived it
and wanted to see it made accessible and
affordable to the citizens of new
hampshire and pressed forward
this work
chairman pearson of the house and human
services oversight committee in his
wisdom
saw fit to bring this up before that
committee
and to move it forward and i am
confident that on the 24th of this month
when that committee meets again he will
appoint a
permanently standing committee a
subcommittee of health and human
services oversight to push this forward
so we've done our work we've done it
well and i wish to thank all the members
of the ad hoc committee for what they
contributed
you can be confident representative
soloway that representative pearson will
speak through the mouth of
representative edwards because i will be
in atlanta with the cdc and
representative canark so my vice chair
will be in the meeting presiding on the
24th but you and i can talk more fully
about um what representative edwards
will say that i said that you mean
i think i get that right
thank you so much for pulling all of
this together
and sir i also look to you for a motion
that it is not recommended
for
further study i already made one but
i'll withdraw it if you'd prefer if we
may so i defer to representative weber
rocks paper scissors
if you defer um
we will ask representative webber for a
motion
which you already made but repeat it
please i i would move not recommended
for further legend and i will second it
any further discussion
the motion before us is
house bill 1290 establishing a task
force on precision medicine and
biomarker testing
move by weber represe
seconded by the chair
would the clerk please call the roll
representative leon yes
representative mcmahon yeah
representative acton representative gay
representative cushman is absent
representative folsom is absent
representative kelsey yes represent king
is absent representative cofoult yes
representative delemus is absent
representative weber
representative mckay
representative snow yeah representative
kanerk
yes
representative soloway
representative cannon yeah
representative nutter uppam
representative shapiro yes
representative woods yes
representative merchant yes
representative pearson yes
17-0 representative soloway since i
allowed you to defer to representative
webber would you write the committee
report please
thank you
appreciate that very much representative
soloway and that ends 1290 and that ends
this meeting
and it's been a fun two years with
everybody we really worked hard together
but we didn't always agree but really
tried to whenever we could is it likely
that we're to come back in september or
october or anything
veto not there's a veto day but i don't
think because the committee has finished
its work i don't know what the committee
would come back because these will
the reports will go in and the bills
will no longer be in the possession of
the committee but i would just like to
say on a personal level
to extend my thanks to the chair
for his work of the last two years i
very much appreciate it
so i've had other committee chairs say
to me
how do you do it
and i said you got to have a committee
like this
that's how we do it representative snow
yes
regrettably and
not that my
choosing i'm unable to run for
re-election this time
due to health reasons at home with my
wife and my personal mobility is
somewhat more limited than i expected
so i'm really unable to continue but i
did want to thank this group the
leadership of the group and the members
it's an unusual committee where we have
different people with very different
points of view and yet we always
interact in a way that's courteous and
respectful and i really appreciate it
i'll never forget it thank you
thank you
representative snow if you see a hearing
that looks interesting to you i hope you
can come and we promise to turn your mic
on for you
mr chairman
we're supposed to
sign in today
oh yeah
the sign-in
chart
and of all people who needs his mileage
representative mckay we will get you
your 0.4 miles
representative woods
thank you mr chair um thank you for
my last time as well i will not be
running for a variety of reasons
uh specifically uh for
i'm gonna be moving from bow back into
concord
um at any rate it's been a pleasure
i've worked with the legislature
since 1982 in a variety of positions and
so forth
um and this has certainly been very
pleasurable on my part
uh to and privilege uh to serve in this
capacity
um
it's
awe-inspiring in many ways
and
i i'm glad i did run i'm glad i've had a
chance to serve
i've gained so much
um
over the course of years
i honestly felt and when i knocked doors
i told people
i've been so privileged in many ways i
felt i owed something back
and i tried to do that and i appreciate
those who
would listen to my
physics as we went along it's still
i realize it's a bit of a bore
but it it really is
oh
explain your pun
[Laughter]
oh
um
again i just want to thank everybody and
i've i've thoroughly enjoyed it and
um i the sidebar i i although i'm
retired i was able to do several hand
consults over the course of time and
that was i was
enjoyable as well
uh and i i honestly say that i um i've
always told my daughters
uh they would come and we didn't have
any more we just had three girls and
uh i'd always expected at least one boy
to you know be the sports person
uh but so you had to i had to be a
little bit more cautious and so i uh
when i interact
they would come in and
so i would challenge them
and they would say well what if i i i
want to do such and such
um
well that sounds reasonable what about
the other argument on the other side
and of course with three teenage
daughters in the house at once i all i
would get would be the roll of the eyes
dad
so i said you do understand
that if you only can argue one side even
though you may be right but if you can
only argue one side by definition you're
prejudiced
that's the definition of being
prejudiced so my comment being
until you can argue both sides
come back another day
and i
take that personally and i must say that
i have learned
a lot
from everybody
i think it's appropriate we give him a
thank you very much no
and and speaking of your exhortation to
take the other side i'm in a
what is it a
program would you explain what i'm doing
in that group
with you and representative shapiro
that is for students at unh oh
it's it's not unh it's aarp it's the
aarp leadership program and they
are
training
seniors to be advocates on
both in the community and at the
legislature for
issues that affect seniors and we are
participating
in their day on legislative action i get
to argue against
103 the dental bill which i took point
on on the floor
with the assurance that that little
sound bite would not be separated from
you know my wife says don't do it it's a
trap
and i know it won't be but anyway i get
to argue the negative side against you
it should be fun anyone else not coming
back who wants to say a few words
yes masked man
i ain't coming back
i want to thank you all i have learned
so so very much i genuinely feel
privileged uh you've been wonderful
teachers i'm very grateful thanks
anyone else anyone else we know
definitely is not coming back
you're not
you're not allowed to talk
representative delemus is not coming
back she's moving out of her district i
think we're losing one or two more are
we
on our side are we
representative folsom is not coming back
uh she's moving as well to a different
place
well i've been redistricted into a very
heavily republican district so i'm going
to try
but i'm probably not going to be here
either
i might hold a sign for you i'll put a
mask on but i might hold a sign for you
thank you everyone
you